well let's get to o.j o.j simpson's
lawyers say they don't want the families
of nicole brown and ronald goldman in
the courtroom during the trial
they're afraid the presence of the
family members will just remind oj of
how much more
killing he still has to do
you know and white people when y'all get
mad at us
like over the o.j thing you remember
that
one [ __ ] [ __ ] up they want to kill all
of us
[ __ ] oj that's not our [ __ ]
that's y'all [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying after he [ __ ] up you want to send
him back to us we don't want him
that's y'all [ __ ] he never killed
nobody when he hung out with [ __ ]
god with y'all chop chop stab stab
we knew he wasn't a [ __ ] from the
[ __ ] commercials
only [ __ ] that can run through the
airport
through security nobody touching
let one of us in here run through the
[ __ ] airport
click click get down get down
and the pope came out with a book this
week which contains a series of essays
examining faith and morality in today's
secular world
and the changing role of the catholic
church as it approaches the 21st century
the book is entitled god himself told me
that oj is guilty
but no he gonna go put out a tape his
version
he's not a smart man you know he's
starting to tape off
trying to discredit his wife now she did
can't defend herself
uh first of all
it is ludacrisp
not to be confused with super sugar
crisp
to think that i would want to kill
nicole see
that was some old [ __ ] for me
you know i tapped that a few times
dropped a few captain i was moving on to
some bigger better whiter women
i mean everybody i know [ __ ] nicole
brown
marcus allen byron allen woody allen
ethan allen
debbie allen all your name man to me was
that
now i want to walk you all through this
supposed crime scene
that's right they say i supposedly
jumped over this wall here on the night
in question
now if you know me from football
or maybe one of my hurts commercials
where i jump over the car
or as of lately the high impact aerobic
tape
you know i got bad knees ashy bad knees
there's no way i could have jumped over
this wall and i'mma demonstrate to you
i'ma show you with the condition of my
knee
there's no way i could have got over
this walker oh damn
my knee
see so that's half a miss marsha case
just right out the window
now here's the kicker they say i
allegedly
dropped a glove at the scene of the
crime
now i played football what some 29 some
odd years
never once did i drop the ball how the
[ __ ] i'mma drop a glove at the scene of
the ground
look my hands is a train machine i can
hold on to anything under any
circumstance
you know and beside the glove just ain't
going to slip off no hand this big
you see how big my hand is i could wipe
my ass and scratch my head at the same
time
now i'mma demonstrate to you there's no
way i could have dropped no glove at the
scene of crime because my hands are so
good now i want you to take this ball
and i want you to throw it you throw it
any way you want and i'ma catch it
i don't care where you throw it you know
what
throw it over the wall
[Applause]
you see there's no way i would have
dropped that glove
in other book news prince charles
released an autobiography in which
he states that he never loved princess
die and that his father pressured him to
marry her
the book is entitled of course o.j did
it i mean come on
[Music]
a lot of racial [ __ ] this [ __ ] a lot of
racial [ __ ] was the big thing oj
oj was big that's right black people too
happy white people too mad
white people are like bam this is
[ __ ] i see white people that mad
since they cancelled mash
black people waiting to ever yeah we won
yes
we won what the [ __ ] did we win
every day i look at the mailbox for my
oj prize nothing
no oh it's all about race that [ __ ]
wasn't about race
that [ __ ] was about fame cause if oj
wasn't famous he'd be in jail right now
oj drove a bus
if oj drove a bus he wouldn't even be
o.j he'd be orentho the bus driving
murderer
and everybody jury's so stupid [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out of here man
they're so stupid how could they not
white people would have done the exact
same [ __ ] okay the exact
same [ __ ] cause that was jerry seinfeld
charged with double murder and the only
person that found the glove just
happened to be in the nation of islam
in his book o.j simpson says that he
would have taken a bullet or stood in
front of a train for nicole
man i'm going to tell you that is some
bad luck when the one guy who would have
died for you
kills you that's private
[Applause]
you don't get worse luck than that oj
simpson up
why won't he just sit down just go home
just sit down you
embarrassing everybody then got stopped
again
on some silly [ __ ] he gonna end up going
back to jail for some just go sit down
somewhere
and what makes me think he's always
guilty is that walk
every time i see that walk i think he
did it you seen me
he wiping blood off his shoe and [ __ ]
[Applause]
he look like he's gonna kill somebody
yeah i'll kill you [ __ ]
i'll kill again
thanks i'm norm mcdonald and now the
fake news
well it is finally official murder
is legal in the state of california
what's that white man's name used to
play superman christopher reeves
put him in the car with o.j said chris
stay here he'll walk his ass up out of
there
they're gonna mess with no goddamn oj oj
is super [ __ ]
kill two people not get a drop of blood
chase the dog away and still have time
to catch this plane
that's super [ __ ]
i can't eat a bean burrito without
messing my shirt up i don't kill nobody
i'm always late for my flight
super [ __ ]
from seeing that [ __ ] brought back to oj
trial that trial was deep
because they had johnny oh johnny you
know johnny johnny talks more
[ __ ] than than jesse jackson the message
jesse
and jesse got messy we had a perfect
[ __ ] record to jesse got messy
telling us to stay out of the bush no
you stay out the bush [ __ ]
with that old ass baby i tried to help
jessie hide that old baby
they caught us the baby probably called
the press that's an old baby
the baby was shaving
but johnny don't johnny talk [ __ ] baby
johnny can get you off
that [ __ ] rhyme they got a little [ __ ]
go that [ __ ] can rhyme you out of jail
he got he got uh o.j off with that glove
it don't fit a quit
nicole was a hoe you gotta let him go
that [ __ ] will run he got puffy off
what puppy changed his name to what
oh should have changed into lucky [ __ ]
cause he was
he rhymed him out the gun wasn't in the
car
it wasn't at the bar
[Applause]
that oj trial was deep wasn't it and
white folks can talk to animals they
wore that dog
out was it akita a japanese dog did they
wear that dog out
come on we'll give you a show like
lassie a gentle ben oh yellow
come on you saw oj do it say oh jay
did it come on dog the dog tried oh oh
that's it that's a dog come on you're
almost there oh oh
oh oh yes you're almost there come on
dog you can do it
oj say it was a japanese akita couldn't
pronounce the j oh
couldn't pronounce that goddamn j
if it would have been an english terrier
we'd have been in trouble yes it was o.j
since
[Applause]
the [ __ ] that you call the jews
it was very violent
there was blood everywhere
[Applause]
i ran like a bunny rabbit i
kept screaming god save the queen
[Music]
and there's charles woodson how about
that i don't know what a season he had
great manny he became the first
defensive player to win the heisman
trophy and congratulations charles
that is something that no one can ever
take away from you
unless you kill your wife and a waiter
in which case
all deaths are off
o.j simpson one of the nicest man i've
ever met
he was nice to me he's nice to my
friends
the conversation was filled with warmth
and levity humor and wisdom
he talked for 90 minutes and then
suddenly the jew said you know what
i've got to be going but it's good to
see you again
and i'm glad things went so well i said
thanks juice
and my friend said yeah goodbye mr juice
they're new to the game
he said no thank you for your
hospitality
good night guys and we said good night
and he just walked out of the room
and as soon as the door closed we all
looked at each other like that [ __ ] did
that [ __ ]
[Music]
i feel like
murder in the room